on dirait que rien ne lui fait peur et
sûrement pas la pluie qui tombe ce jour
là sur le stade de la redoute
chelsea a débarqué deux heures plus tôt
de l'avion elle vient de passer quatre
jours à paris pour ces tests d'entrée au
pôle france elle n'a pas beaucoup dormi
mais elle ne voudrait pour rien au monde
rater le derby entre le stéphane et son
club le saint denis fc chelsea
paillettes et numéro 9
ailier gauche dans l'équipe des garçons
de 15 ans elle est la seule fille alors
pour se changer
elle s'isole un peu mais le fait que
chelsea est une fille est vite oublié le
match va commencer
chelsea n'est pas la capitaine mais
c'est elle qui lance le cri de guerre de
son équipe et quand celle ci joue le
douzième homme sur le terrain c'est papa
qui commente le match en direct avec
maman ouais mais regarde 1 2 3 4 5
arrive alors jacques pas d'où il a été
le premier à repérer de chelsea
[Musique]
jacques pas d'eau et éducateur au saint
denis fc
et il connaît très bien sa petite
protégée qualité de chelsea a beaucoup
de volonté
beaucoup d'opiniâtreté ah oui ça j'ai un
bâton et n'aime pas perdre
cette sixième pas perdre à huy moi j'ai
une anecdote je rappelle un tournoi où
il fallait à tout prix manqué le penalty
c'était ainsi elle a pas mal et on a été
éliminés
et alors on était là mais à qui elle a
pleuré elle a pleuré devant tout le
monde était inconsolable
chelsea a toujours joué avec les garçons
deuxième faute et ça lui a sans doute
permis de sortir cyr il ya un monsieur
l'armée toutes les filles ont réussi en
général ils ont joué en mixité et et
après l'agressivité monte au fur et à
mesure est à fait normal l'important
pour nous tous les jouer avec les
garçons oui pour plus progressé c'est
plus intense
ce hpv le derby s'achève finalement sur
le score de 2 buts à 1 en faveur du
saint denis fc
[Applaudissements]
après le match retour à la maison
chelsea n'a même pas encore eu le temps
de déballer ses bagages ni de raconter à
sa maman son séjour à paris pendant ces
quatre jours
c'était bel et bien vous l'avez koala
plutôt men entretien avec le site ce
qu'on apprenne à jouer un match c'est
maman qui déballent alors oui tu m'aides
une excuse ça fait combien de temps que
joue six ans des marmailles kelis inef
maison non mais c'est quoi
dès lundi en équipe de france
[Musique]
en attendant chelsea poursuit sa vie de
pensionnaires au pôle espoir de la
plaine des cafres
[Musique]
les journées en citant leur entrée dans
le centre de la plaine des cafres
accueille 47 jeunes de 13 et 14 ans tous
espèrent devenir un jour footballeur au
basketteur professionnel
là bas c'est parce que le procès des
fidèles
jamais
oui
et du coup on rentre dès les poules
manon elle aussi s'apprête à rejoindre
l'hexagone au pôle espoir de tours les
deux amis seront séparés la semaine mais
elles se retrouveront le week-end sur le
terrain car elles ont été recruté par le
paris fc
ben non tout montre lui tu viens juste
dans l'alignement avec elle pour dire je
suis ton soutien il est maintenant huit
heures et c'est parti pour deux heures
d'entraînement muscles à pau c'est
claude lowitz le directeur du pôle
espoir qui dirige la séance
celle ci appuie soutien profondeur dans
les années 80 claude lowitz a joué dans
les plus grands clubs de france psg
marseille nantes avant de finir sa
carrière à la jeanne d'arc
aujourd'hui il est comme un père pour
les jeunes réunionnais moi moi je
voulais faire un point avec toi parce
que ça fait un petit moment que je t'ai
pas vu chelsea lui raconte alors son
séjour à paris et son entrée au pôle
france où toi qu'est ce que tu penses de
ce projet là mais seulement c'est un
autre projet qui commence
est ce que tu en a conscience là il n'ya
pas papa il n'y a pas un moment il n'y a
pas de grand mère un falloir que tu sois
courageux claude lowitz se fait alors
plus intimes
car comme nous depuis le début de ce
reportage il doit souvent se contenter
d'un oui d'un nom quelques mots en
réponse à ces questions il va falloir
aussi que tu t'ouvres que tu souris un
peu plus un c'est une charmante jeune
fille on le sait faut pas que tu aies
peur de dire les choses il faut pas que
tu aies peur de t'exprimer faut pas que
tu aies peur d'aller vers les autres et
parlé et je vais vous présenter
après la douche nous retrouvons chelsea
pour un autre genre d'entraînement
j'ai commencé un fou à l'âge de 9 ans
avec mon père elle répète la
présentation qu'elle devra faire dans
quelques jours devant le jury du brevet
des collèges fusion dans l'idéal
j'aimerais être footballeur
professionnel jouant bien et mon plan b
si je ne réussis pas bon je voudrais te
qui mise et kinésithérapeutes car il n'y
a pas que le football
tous les jours après l'entraînement les
jeunes du pôle espoir rejoignent le
collège de la plaine des cafres chelsea
redevient alors une collégienne comme
les autres à 14 ans elle a encore toute
la vie devant elle et elle la rave en
bleu
[Musique]
ça va